hello in this video i explain to you
what the correlation analysis is and how
you can calculate a
correlation analysis and with that we start right away the correlation analysis examines the
linear connection of variables one
question could be, for example,
there is a connection between the
age at which a child starts  sentences
speaks and the later school
success is of course of interest how
strong this correlation is how strong
the correlation is results from the
coalition coefficient which
fluctuates between minus 1 and 1 to put the strength of the
correlation or the connection
into words you can use
this table  use on the
left side the amount of the
coalition coefficient is listed and
on the right side you can
read off
the strength of the association the strength of the association goes from
no association to high association in
addition to the strength of the association
there are of course also the  direction
of the correlation you can have either
a positive or a negative
correlation or the
correlation there is a positive correlation when
larger values ​​of one variable are associated with
larger values ​​of the other
variable,
for example height and shoe
size if you are tall, it is
quite likely that  you also have a
large shoe size, so these two
variables have a positive
correlation
with a positive correlation, there
is a positive relations'
coefficient, i.e. a correlation sco
efficient that is greater than zero and
therefore lies between 0 and 1, there is a
negative correlation when
larger values  of one variable associated with
smaller values ​​of the other
variable an example is
the product price and the sales
quantity typically if you increase the product
price the sales quantity decreases
therefore we have a negative
correlation an increase in the
product price results  to reduce
the sales volume with the negative
correlation, there is a negative
correlation efficiently, i.e. a
correlation school 5 cents less than 0,
so it lies between minus one and
zero, summarized again, a
positive correlation exists if we have
a coalition copy ducks between 0
and 1 a  negative correlation
exists when we have a correlation sco
efficient between minus one and
zero to calculate the coalition course tenth one
usually uses the
coalition analysis according to pierson or the
spearmon rank correlation
i will show you both again now
you can easily calculate online
go for this  you simply click on date up de
and then click on the statistics
calculator
in this table you can now copy your
own data into it before
you have to click on table teachers
I'll just use the example
data record it's important that the variable
names are in the first row we
want  en calculate a correlation so
click on the correlation tab
then the
variables that you have up here in the
table appear down here say we want to
check whether there is a correlation
between age and income then
we simply click on income and age
here we can now select whether we want to calculate the
pierson coalition or the spearman
coordination
let's just start with the ps in
combination
if we now scroll down
we already get the results
for the pea rsn coalition
we see that the age and the
income  in this example correlated with 0 569
we would
like to calculate the company coalition let's
just click on the game here
we'll stay with the ps and
correlation for a moment if you like
you can summarize the result of the coalition
analysis in words
then you'll get the text up here  how
you can interpret the correlation
a pierson correlation became  e
carried out to test whether there is a
relationship between income and
age the results of the pierson
coalition show that there was no
significant relationship between
income and age whether the
correlation is significant or not
you can also read the table below if
you want to know what it means
to check a correlation for significant
and how to interpret the result
then just watch
my first video
bye and see you next time